college football playoff rankings are
out for the first time in 2017 Brad
Nessler the voice of the SEC on CBS will
join us in our number three but I am I
am turning to my right and thrilled to
have sitting here in person here on this
show someone who I got a chance to meet
way back in the day a few times but now
fresh off of a symposium that I
moderated at the Milken conference that
included maverick Carter co-founder of
on interrupted and Spring Hill
entertainment here on the show courtesy
of maverick thank you for having me I
appreciate it you travel all over how
often are you on planes work at home
with you more than I would like but I
try and minimize it okay as much as I
can how much time do you spend going to
games then do you go to a lot of games
or not really not really
I don't NBA games I go to a few you know
but not as I used to go to a whole I
used to probably average 16 a year
accounting playoffs now I'm probably
down there like 10 10 15 okay and you go
as a fan at all or I definitely go as a
fan I have not lost my fandom okay as
I've become a part of the industry yes
and obviously my partner is LeBron I
still go as a fan I still go to
appreciate the game and appreciate the
athletes playing and they so who do you
appreciate outside of obviously 23 in
basketball yeah um because I'm a huge
NFL fan and I'm a baseball playoff fan I
was at the game last night okay I'm
trying to avoid the subject of football
with you god okay I get it you know
because I understand what your your
collegiate rooting interest is you're
trying to avoid the subject of football
with me because I'm from Akron Ohio and
rich obviously has the Michigan House
desk if you noticed it's somewhat
prominent leaders you know there's a
rumor going around based on what's been
happening over their last like 20 years
if they're gonna change the name of the
University of Michigan to the the
University of Ohio State of Ann Arbor
campus for Houston
that's just a rumor so you should hold
on to that diploma it'll be worth some
noaina maverick I know I have a few
years on you there was a guy named John
Cooper once upon a time
that's true and even with the recent
success I wouldn't I wouldn't pegged it
at 20 years if I had to choose a year
you know I don't know if it's 20 okay
but but I understand the trestle limit
of the toy okay this is why I was trying
to avoid this tried each okay but it's
the series the all-time series now it's
time everyone always Oh everyone because
the president of uninterrupted went to
the University of Michigan he's an
african-american guy and he says the
series all time is this I said you
accounting games when african-americans
could even play UK I'm like you can't do
that 1902 well I guess yes and be like
Babe Ruth I can't help but notice then
that one of the most successful branders
and businesspeople in our in our sports
world and entertainment world nationally
and internationally chooses as the
president of their company a universe
this is the one at all matters and
business in the planning maverick Carter
we knew all matters where do you go got
from the University of mission that is
true well now it's gonna be the house
state of University Almighty now
seriously growing up in that so you you
were growing up the real this is a real
deal okay in fact I also tell him this
this is another little everything great
that's happened at the University of
Michigan football came from Ohio
this man Cleveland Charles Dayton yeah
Schembechler hardball autumn or Les
Miles us from Ohio Schembechler Mohan
well I know I both from the cradle
coaches my fellow huh what he Hayes was
a mentor fish I go to a game as a fan
I'm a fan of Westbrook just players I
love Westbrook I love I love the
Warriors the thing they love about the
Warriors and what makes them great is
their attitudes towards the game their
chemistry so what that's what makes them
pree Kevin Durant now with Kevin Durant
obviously he makes them extremely lethal
but pre Kevin Durant the best part about
the Warriors was their chemistry the
fact that klay Thompson was fine always
guarding the much tougher guard whether
that guard was a point guard or whether
that guard was a to guard he took them
but Steph got all the Acolytes they've
got the MVPs most time in basketball
if I'm the to guard and you're the point
guard and the other team's best player
is their point guard and I guard him
then I should get I feel it and then I
can score too and play as well as Claire
does I want the accolades too I would go
well rich if you're gonna get the
accolades in MVPs you gotta guard your
guy I may never do that they just play
the game the way it's supposed to be so
I love that the Warriors I love again
Westbrook I love Anthony Davis right now
my favorite player to watch town and
LeBron is the Greek freak and he's
incredible it's just like Yanis is truly
just taking it and I don't want to put
anything on it all right I mean it's
just three weeks but you could see that
he has taken a giant
what he began to do in the playoffs last
year absolutely and if I told you I
didn't look at the numbers this morning
but like as of you know through five
games a guy is averaging 35 points and
shooting 60% from the field you go Oh
Shaq is back and he hasn't made a jumper
nice he hasn't made one jumper he's
everything imagine you could score 35
points and you're gonna you don't have
to make a jumper and that's amazing
don't shoot jumpers I love Greek freak I
love I love watching Tyrese fantastic
with the ball I mean there's nobody
better with the ball and he's like a
wizard with the ball and the thing I
love about watching Kyrie the most he's
always loose he plays in NBA games and
playoff games and finals games like he's
at a playground you'd think he's playing
like a pickup game and he's in the
middle of crucial game stuff that has
that a little bit to where they just
play loose they just kind of always lose
some letting the fly and letting it go
maverick Carter here
on the Rich Eisen show a co-founder of
uninterrupted as we mentioned I couldn't
help but notice looking at all the
athletes that are on uninterrupted
providing content conducting interviews
documentaries is a great one with Al
Harrington that we're gonna show to our
television audience in a second
I saw dream on down there I mean so
draymond Green and and team LeBron were
all cool that all good I love draymond
Green draymond Green is a the the best
quality about him as a basketball player
as a person he's he's super intelligent
he picks up on things super quick super
smart I think that's his best skill as a
basketball I think he would probably
agree as a basketball player the best
thing that he does is the attitude he
brings to the game and the intelligence
he brings to the game he's by far the
centerpiece of what I was saying I'm the
fan of the water that chemistry of that
knowing doing only what you know how to
do sticking to your thing they do that
and he's the centerpiece and he's the
driving force behind that's no secret
everyone says it Bob Myers their GM
talks about it Steve Kerr does so I
loved Ramon as a smart guy
very intelligent guy very outspoken guy
so perfect for what we do is you know
telling stories with athletes
uninterrupted he always has a story to
tell or in the share yeah I know he sure
does
and I I was wondering what and you know
about uninterrupted why did you guys at
Spring Hill Entertainment and everybody
else and team LeBron as you would call
it wanted to get into this business whoa
and interrupted what we we wanted to
because I've myself have always been the
storytelling business I worked at Nike
that's why I started my career yeah and
as I tell people like he's really a
storytelling company they happened to
sell footwear and apparel instead of
movie tickets and subscriptions to a
channel but they really don't ever talk
much about their product or the price of
it they definitely never tell you the
price of it they just tell you fantastic
stories about Michael Jordan and Serena
Williams Roger Federer Neymar and LeBron
they just tell you these amazing stories
and it moves you emotionally and that's
where I graduated when people asked me
what college did you graduate from
I say Nike and if you can tell me a
better marketing and branding school in
sports I don't think there's one out
there so and then with LeBron he and I
being partners and me managing his
career off the court
I've always been telling stories my
whole life and then obviously when
LeBron changed teams twice though yeah I
heard that you heard that right that's
the first time we did a television show
with which with your old company yes
that everyone said was disaster horrible
and though I agreed not produced well it
still is to this day the highest ranking
non live sports thing on that network of
all time and one of the highest-ranked
non sports thing on cable and paid cable
so and now everybody does that
everybody's telling stories then when
ESPN has a whole show for high school
kids to do it now to pick their college
and in the second time when he changed
again I love you heard breaking news yes
yeah is breaking news he changed again
he did the same thing in control his
message but he wrote it in a letter and
everyone loved it and that was in July a
14 in that letter he wrote a line that
was the inspiration for the businesses
I'm writing this letter instead of doing
a press conference because I want to get
all my thoughts out without any
interruption and it that line literally
we put out the letter we literally two
hours later we were on a plane flying to
Brazil to go to the World Cup final and
went to see the Germany Argentina match
and after too much wine and talking
about the letter we came up with the
idea that we should build a digital
media company that's distributed
everywhere that allows athletes to tell
the stories that matter to them and
uninterrupted calm and there's a a great
documentary about 15 minutes were long
14 and change with Al Harrington who is
now suddenly deep into the cannabis
business and his sit-down interview with
David Stern about the subject which was
awesome to see and we'll show that on
the TV side first but I do want to ask
you this before we take our first break
and we'll come back if you could go in
the Wayback Machine what would you
change from that decision show maverick
for
the first decision show what would you
change a lot I would I wouldn't change I
would still do it we would do that show
we would take over the media and give
the three and a half million dollars of
charity the production of the show would
change just how the show was literally
produced I was an experienced at all in
TV production in ESP and obviously I
turned it over to them I would change
how the show laid out how it rolled out
I would change the production of the
ship how long it took for him to how
long it took the takes they're kind of
dragging it out I would that's the only
thing I would change about the show but
I would still do it 100% would you want
a different host say somebody that's
sitting across from you right now man
yeah I think that would work maybe you
know we could do it on the Richard show
maybe we take it out now we're getting
well certainly if there might be another
decision to be made in the next day like
the University of Michigan guys this
really smart guys learn things the right
way when it matters really laying the
rubber meets the road someone from Akron
who would know that phrase the road
exactly I'll take a break and touch upon
that subject and more with maverick
Carter before Adam Schefter joins us
here on this edition of the Rich Eisen
show
welcome back to the riches and show Adam
Schefter joining us in a moment maverick
Carter of the business partner of LeBron
James for well over a decade now here on
the Rich Eisen show how do you and
LeBron choose what you get involved in
business was oh that is a great question
and we you know you're right it has been
over a decade now since I left Nike and
became partners with LeBron but we
choose based on things that a first and
foremost if we're gonna invest in it the
people who are gonna run this business
who are gonna be the managers we're
gonna focus on this business day to day
because that's most important I focus on
uninterrupted and springy all day today
so if we put an investment I can't focus
on something else day today so we it's
really about the people a and B things
that we really either like and or
authentic to us and we feel like if we
get involved we can actually move the
needle we can actually get first downs
with this business to be it ideas be
putting LeBrons face on it putting his
name on it but most importantly is the
people we really want to be in business
with people we like people we think are
gonna bust their butt every day and
build this business and build this
company and people that we want to do
business with and that you know because
a lot of times you do business with
someone if it works out or it doesn't
you end up making friends and those are
people you're going to do other things
with so just reading it two things so
LeBron likes pizza game shows you the
the so using Blais that's a great
example sure Blais came to us I wouldn't
looked at the concept before it was
launched I met the gentleman who was
starting a guy named Rick Wetzel might
be familiar because everyone's pretty
much heard of Wetzel's pretzels my gosh
I'm going to an airport shortly exactly
so what's Rick Wetzel started what's
those purses and when I met him we
started talking about how well what's
those pretzels did and I got the feeling
he didn't make a whole lot of money like
he made a lot of money but he didn't
like he wasn't he obviously didn't make
enough to retire cuz he had a new
business idea that's what I knew so I
said to myself I went back to LeBron and
I saw this concept that's incredible I
think it's gonna work LeBron statement
was who doesn't like pizza which I agree
with them that
so let's check one mmm I told them that
you ever met the guy yet but the guy
running it imagined you LeBron is
competitive you competitive as you are
had to wake up every single day and know
that there was 400 restaurants called
LeBrons and you didn't make all the
money you'd want to kill somebody you'd
wake up every day a killer I'm betting
on that guy he's he's gonna make this
into something he used to wake up every
day and see Wetzel's pretzels but he
didn't make enough money to retire so
that you know that guy that person is
gonna Buster but they're hungry they
don't want to lose and the third thing
is LeBron had a long-lasting
relationship with McDonald's and it was
just time to move on so this is the
perfect next thing to do so those are
the three reasons we did it maverick
Carter here in the Rich Eisen show how
important is it to where he plays
basketball
these were your decision-making these
days it doesn't matter anymore you could
be think about it now the the Lakers and
the Knicks have been bad
the Knicks for a very long time the
Lakers for I don't know since Kobe kind
of aged out of being the best player or
one of the best players in the league
and basketball is growing and doing as
great as ever with teams in Oklahoma
City and Cleveland these days it doesn't
matter because you could be known and be
a star from anywhere anywhere in the
world so it doesn't actually matter I
mean could he sell a few more sneakers
if he was in a gigantic market like
Boston or Chicago or in New York or LA
maybe but not but not as much as if he
wins what matters the most is if he wins
when you win as an athlete that matters
the most well let me just cut straight
to the heart of the matter if you don't
mind I mean Los Angeles but your
spring-heeled entertainment we all have
seen he crushed it and LeBron crushed it
and trainwreck yeah it was good it was
good
terrific he was terrific you know John
Cena was terrific in it too well LeBron
out Shawn him anyway reason why bring it
up is it makes sense okay if he wants to
be in movies if you and as a business
model wanna go in the entertainment
direction certainly when he's phasing
out of his professional playing career
Los Angeles makes perfect sense
is there any there there to that part of
the conversation maverick the reason I
understand people keep saying that and
thinking that but the reason it doesn't
make sense is because if he plays in LA
or he plays on the moon he can only
shoot movies for three months it's not
like it doesn't matter even if he played
in LA and he wanted to be in a movie he
can't shoot from basically September to
June but he can make he could take a
meeting in an off day
in between - he also could do that from
these days from anywhere in the world a
and B we're doing fine without him
living here and playing here and he
comes you know he's a home here in the
off season he does in LA in the
offseason our company we have you know
ten shows and development I mean ten
shows and deals we have two shows with
Netflix you know a show with HBO and
none of them are starring Hammer he is
he's just the EP and I'm running the
company you know as a founder of the
company with me so he doesn't we the
company doesn't need him to be here and
if he wants to act in movies it doesn't
matter because he only gets three months
a year to do it anyway no matter where
he so knowing what you know and being
your question about a meeting yes he's
LeBron rich people like it actually
works you know I mean like if LeBron
says I want to have a meeting or someone
was that meet and he's like I'm in you
know Detroit and it's 10 below people go
we got coats there's coach there's
enough players people everywhere so
people will layer for LeBron so people
so then again knowing what you know let
all of us in the media in on when should
we really start focusing on what LeBrons
decision-making is for his next playing
career step when is it now is it now
always leading in everything he never
starts thinking about it before the end
of the season so I would say whenever
their season ends hopefully it's in June
for his sake and for the sake of his
family because he goes crazy at home I
would say he usually like a week after
decompresses
let's it all calm down than a week after
sometimes you could take a little longer
but at least a week after this okay
maverick Carter here on the Rich Eisen
show uninterrupted comm check it all out
for all this all of the the neat pieces
of content that's on their videos and
documentaries lovers of sport athletes
and fans it's a digital media company
totally dedicated to that it is great to
see you Thank You chef ders calling in
he is he blowing you up trying to get no
no yeah come on now I know that he
called me blew me up when they start
letting him do basketball that's what I
say it was so funny he's good I mean cuz
he's a big NBA fantasy ring is he
calling you for information sometimes
not yet okay cuz he's not he's not stop
like he's non-stop
okay at Mavs Carter on Twitter please oh
hopefully this is first too many times I
absolutely this studio and some really
love it and certainly if you ever need a
Michigan man for anything absolute you
know what a finding that's messed up for
football well you know if you need any
NFL tips by the way you know where he
went to school we're to go Michigan are
you serious I'm saying I will call it
Michigan man for anything except to play
football cause you guys don't do that
Tom Brady Tom Brady I do how many holes
can I poke I love Tom's a friend of mine
I love time okay let's show alright
maverick Carter you're on the Rich Eisen
show back in 60 seconds with Adam for
more Rich Eisen show tuned - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
doesn't show up